on the hill tonight for the giants will
be the right-handed veteran johnny cueto
in his 13th year at the big league level
he's 34 years of age and uh this is what
he has done he's 2-0 with a 4-3-5 era 27
strikeouts in 31 innings mookie with two
home runs on sunday and now seven home
runs over his last 10 games
got him and that's how this game gets
started one going here in the first and
up comes corey seeger
now first ball swinging seeker lines one
of the right field for a base hit
hustling over to his
left to cut it off at the edge of the
warning track is just and seeger will
hold it first with a single up comes
turner but has reached in 17 consecutive
games slips a fly ball to right center
field here that sends the ski back and
it's off his glove
seeger headed for third turn to second
the throw is late the dodgers in
business here in the first and so this
first inning opportunity left to the
birthday boy happy 30th to max muncie
that ball is crushed right center field
yaskrimsky turns it's gone
happy birthday max muncie
a three-run homerun and the dodgers
strike quickly well he didn't quite hit
it in the ocean but
counts the same
giving himself a birthday present
the dodger is a three-run lead
well the dodgers that's their 60th home
run this year
they've hit more than any other national
league team they've averaged two homers
per game
maria's last time out which was
wednesday in seattle four hits and a
walk over just one in two thirds and the
big issue for him has been the first
inning i mean he had to throw 34 pitches
in that first inning against the
mariners
first and second for brandon bell and in
a team full of hot hitters this is the
hottest 5 22 in his last eight games
high drive into center field
bellinger back look it up
out of here
and this game is tied
so brandon belt with a spectacular home
run to tie this game he got a low
fastball 95 miles an hour right down the
middle and boom
belt's fourth home run of the year one
away in the third for seeger who's
averaging two pitches per played
appearance the last few days this one
about to have his sixth
he's hit better after the second pitch
than the first two
drives the ball to right center field
back towards the wall corey zieger hits
it out of here and puts the dodgers back
in front well that trend holds where he
continues to do damage a little bit
later than the cow
he joins cody bellinger and max muncie
with eight home runs both or all three
of those guys in the top five in the
league
the dodgers lead at 4-3
tried to sneak a fastball past seeger
and he was going to have nothing to do
with it burgers at first base with one
out bellinger digs it out strokes it
down the right field line into the
corner
turner headed to third and a ringing
double from bellinger
so second and third one gone and max
muncie comes to the plate again
payoff pitch he walked in it kicks away
and in from third comes turner so they
lead 5-3 pressure on peterson to get it
done with two gone here in the third
that is a fair ball for peterson that
will easily bring home bellinger
muncie stops at third petersen to second
with an rbi double and it's 6-3
it'll be longoria belt and solano
longoria has got another hit and this
one might be where he could try for two
he is going to put on the brakes
there's bellinger and off his perfect
throw that was unbelievable
logo's got two singles and a walk in
this game here comes brandon bell
bell drives one to right mookie bench
looking up and it is off the bricks and
it shoots way away from bets longoria is
going to come in to score
and the giants score here in the fifth
at six to four brandon belt at second
base it is dylan floro enters the game
and here's joey bart
third one gone big one-two pitch coming
here from floro
he strikes him out two-seamer moves like
a screw ball and gets bart swinging two
gone
big time two-seam movement that looked
almost like a left-hander slider starts
off the inside corner and then it just
explodes down towards the back foot he
swings right over the top blake trining
comes on basin wilmer flores
representing the tying run with two gone
here in the sixth
that's caught it third by turner and the
ending is over one left dodgers six to
four and the bases are going to be
loaded and the hitter is going to be
joey bart
get up the middle this will be a pair
that's one
and that's no he beat it out
it's a 6'5 game either way but will be
first and third one out or runner but
third two out they're gonna take a look
and we're waiting to find out from new
york
here's the call
he is out so that's a double play
nearly the worst case scenario
now it's up to kenley janssen to close
the door and seal the deal one out
here's belt three for three four batted
in
belt it's a high drive to center field
on the move is bellinger still on the
move
out of here and this game is tied he's
hot folks
that's his second of the game and it's
six to six so he walks muncie as pollock
comes up garcia's always been a pitcher
he can get a ground ball and maybe the
giants have a chance to turn two
cross up cross up and now turner's
headed for third and the throw gets into
left field
turner headed for the plate and the
dodgers take the lead joey bart he makes
it to third so here's duvon this is the
last hope for the giants
and he wraps this one on the ground
turner's got it and this game is tied
the third goes smith to out turner with
three hits tonight
puts this one in play a little spinner
along first he is safe and the dodgers
take the lead turner with a little two
step up the first base line and here's
longoria
and he's got another one and this game
is going to be tied
here's betsy's throw home it's not in
time
and it's tied up once again
so here's solano
high drive
left field it is out of here
and we are going home
donovan solano sends everybody home
and he will get the heroes welcome
and the giants have won their
seventh straight